Amazon and MGM are putting their heads
together to create a five-year plan but
will Stargate be a part of that plan
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so everything has to be a franchise
nowadays we actually heard David zaslav
over at Warner Brothers talking about
this recently that they are going to be
focusing far more on projects that have
the potential to become franchises
rather than just Standalone films TV
series Etc they want to create wider
universes and that has to be the focus
but why
well speaking to my sources within the
movie and television industry they tell
me that a franchise is really the goose
that lays the golden egg if you think
about Star Wars for Disney anything that
they produce do they put the word Star
Wars on will sell everybody will
desperately wait eagerly for the new
animated series the new game the new
movie
fans go absolutely crazy
they barely have to advertise these
films anymore because social media
idiots like me doing videos do all the
advertising for them and at the end of
the day it's virtually a safe bet that
even if a Star Wars project for Star
Wars do relatively badly it still makes
craploads of money even if the fans hate
it Last Jedi they still make crap loads
of money and people will watch it over
and over again even through gritted
teeth
so the franchise is the goose that lays
the golden egg and that's what Warner
Brothers are really trying to focus on
but they're not the only ones Disney
desperately trying to expand existing
franchises Amazon are looking to maybe
do the same with lots of different
projects that they now own thanks to the
MGM manager
Apple TV plus are desperately looking
for the next big franchise
so MGM and Amazon are coming together
and they're creating a Five-Year Plan
according to my sources A Five-Year Plan
of projects that they think have the
potential to become franchises
now a franchise generally speaking would
mean that we would see projects in the
TV Cinema and straight to movie sort of
area so we would actually get to see
projects created and presented to us in
lots of different ways but also they
want computer games they want Comics
they want to sell toys they want all of
this merch that goes with it and those
are the sort of projects they're
desperately looking for so at the moment
Stargate is definitely up there as part
of those plans they are as I've told you
guys a hundred times before
they're currently looking at potentially
doing a movie first and then moving on
to a television series this is their
grand plan to make Stargate into a new
franchise I genuinely believe this is
why the timekeepers target game is being
held back I think they are waiting for a
Stargate announcement to then release
the game because at the end of the day
they know if they release the game now
it's a Stargate game it'll get a few
Gators buying it if they announce a
movie get a load of people talking about
Stargate again and then release the game
they'll double or triple a sales so
again that's another reason why I
generally think they're holding off
releasing the timekeepers game at the
moment
but again it is that thing about
becoming this franchise I've told you
before many times again the Amazon
consider star going to be a tent pole
project they believe that to be the
project really that they hang a lot of
other things off and that it would be
multiple television series movies games
and potentially merchandise toys etc etc
grown-ups like me We Love Our Stargate
models and things just like we do with
Trek and that is a major Revenue
resource that Amazon can exploit
so what other projects though are they
considering as part of this five-year
project well at the moment they are
looking at 2001 A Space Odyssey that
potentially the last thing I heard was
that it would not become a movie
actually that would become a streaming
TV series for MGM plus think like
Westworld that kind of feel to the
series hopefully the first season not
the crap that followed
um but that is definitely sort of the
way they're going quite I think a slow
burning TV series that would become and
you know lots of mystery lots of reveals
um but generally not a lot of action
they're also looking at a forbidden
planetary reboot now I'm actually
hearing that that is something they
would like to get to turn into a wider
universe so that we would get the
initial movie but that would potentially
kick into
um series and things now apparently
Jennifer sulky who is now head of MGM
movies is very keen to do a Forbidden
Planet movie there are some
complications though because actually
MGM don't solely own the IP rights
Apparently that is the current issue but
they do have a couple of scripts that
have been completed and apparently even
James Cameron would be interested in
getting involved we also know that
they're looking at Rocky and Rambo and
oh no that's not sci-fi but it is still
big MGM and to be honest look the type
of people we're talking about we're
gonna like a rocky or a Rambo series I
like stuff that blows up I just do so a
Rambo series or movies again would be
amazing I'm actually hearing though that
the Rambo project is not intended to be
movies it's tended to be again a series
and it would be based more again around
like Rambo one
um somebody coming back from Afghanistan
somebody with PTSD and again it would be
their fight against some sort of
Injustice I'm thinking more like what we
saw from Amazon with the Jack Reacher
series recently I think he would have
more of that sort of feel to it
um but they're really looking at that
because if I'm being cynical I'm
thinking you take Rambo one and you
create a series and you win loads of
awards and I generally think that's what
they're thinking
they were also thinking about doing the
same potentially with Rocky the success
of Creed one two and about have three
has been massively popular they don't
think they can take Rocky without
Sylvester Stallone back to the cinema
with a new character owned a hard reboot
but they think they could probably get
away with a streaming service series
again would go straight to MGM Plus
the big one though that I think is
really interesting and I think has been
massively under achieving
um in recent years particularly is the
plans to reboot RoboCop now they did the
RoboCop with Michael Keaton a couple
years ago it's bloody awful but whenever
they actually release RoboCop games they
always do really well and that is the
thought that actually RoboCop if they do
a reboot that would actually be a sequel
to the original movie they would ignore
everything else RoboCop 2 RoboCop 3
RoboCop series that terrible RoboCop
from a couple years ago they'll ignore
all of it except for the original movie
and they will expand from there now I'm
here that is actually planned to be a
cinematic release initially but they
would love again for that to become a
bigger project potentially with spin-off
TV series maybe setting that universe
but maybe not immediately around Robocop
and then the movies would come in and
May hopefully maybe even get a couple
but
the more important thing is that we
create a universe a franchise that lots
of different projects can appear in and
around so again we are slowly moving
towards Stargate getting finally
produced but we do have to understand
that MGM was on hold for quite a long
time they didn't have an executive in
charge of movies after Pam Abdi and Mike
DeLuca left they interviewed lots of
people nobody worked out so they ended
up just getting Jennifer sulky from in
charge of Amazon pictures to basically
absorb and take over both roles and he
she is now head of MGM pictures as well
that was not the initial plan but it's
how it's worked out now that only
happens sort of end of November so now
they're actually sitting down together
with Executives from MGM plus as well so
it's the movie and television side of
things and they really are started to
thrash out a hard plan for the next five
maybe even 10 years and once that plan
is sort of thrashed out and they do
decide where they're going and they pick
the projects they then have the most
franchise capability then we'll start
getting some serious announcements
from Stargate what am I hearing at the
moment is that we're still sort of in
the same pattern that we haven't heard
anything by April maybe May then we
should really start becoming concerned
but actually that it is looking like it
will be a movie announced sometime this
year and then potentially a television
series that would be announced early
next year
that's where we're at right now but
let's see what happens
I'd love you guys came to the comments
tell me exactly what you think about
this idea of building franchises rather
than just building projects and
television shows and movies that are
entertaining that everything has to be a
safe bet
I'd love to know exactly what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really answer that and if
you want to become a fully fledged side
tracker and support the channel even
more consider hitting the join button
also if you check the description
there's links to loads of Sidetrack
related things at Discord server
Facebook page Twitter page nine Chevrons
which is our Stargate website and
um goddess other things as well it goes
on and on and on so please go and check
them out and you know pick your poison
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
thank you